thank you to skillshare for supporting
this episode of journey to the micro
cosmos
and if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description you can get a two-month free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
when you go for a walk and you feel
perhaps the
soft squish of nature
underneath your feet you are in fact
walking along the home
of plants and fungi and microbes
the soil itself might just seem like
dirt common ubiquitous mundane
but dirt is essential
it is where everything you eat
comes from it recycles wastes cleans
water
it makes your life better in millions of
tiny ways you never notice
and also it is mysterious
housing a complex network of reactions
between
plants and microbes we can't see it with
our eyes
but it's like an economy built on
chemical signals and
nutrients and competition that take
place
in the microcosmos but that shaped the
macro
world as well now microbes
require water to thrive which can be
challenging in soil
on this channel we've seen many examples
of the protective
cysts that many microbes form when the
habitat around them dries out
like these ciliates that will remain in
this state
until the conditions become right for
them to emerge again
but protective cysts are only a small
part of the story
soil is itself a mix of organic material
minerals water and air
and that fraction of water doesn't just
sustain the plant life we see above
ground it provides a home
to many many microorganisms
that remain hidden below
soil is also not some mound of dirt that
would be
uniform but for the interruption of
animals and plant roots
that world underneath our feet is made
up of
layers and zones for example there's
bulk soil
the area that is untouched by plant
roots
bulk soil is home to microbes
but at the turn of the 20th century a
german scientist
named lorenz hiltner noticed that the
closer the soil
was to a plant's root the higher
bacterial activity he would observe
and from his work he defined not just a
new term
but a whole new world
the world of the rhizosphere
when hiltner defined the rhizosphere in
1904
he described it as the area of the soil
that most immediately surrounded a plant
root
but in time this definition has been
expanded to describe not just the soil
around the
roots but also the parts of the root
that get overtaken by microbes but the
rhizosphere
isn't just a location it's a whole set
of interactions between plants and
microbes
and with the complex ecological
relationship that
builds the soil of the rhizosphere can
actually
look quite different from bulk soil from
the types of nutrients
to its ph but different plants have
different needs and so the rhizosphere
is a dynamic and varied thing that
changes according to microbial
communities
that inhabit it and the complicated
chemical language
they share in the big picture
roots provide structure to plants but
they also
play an important role in the
rhizosphere sending out chemical signals
that attract
microbes these chemicals can include
everything
from free oxygen to water to enzymes to
mucilage to proteins to all sorts of
other things
collectively these compounds are known
as the root
exudate and they might be part of a
plant's waste that gets excreted
through the root and into the
surroundings or they might be released
either actively or passively from root
cells
very broadly the role of root exudate is
to attract microbes
in some terms you could consider it an
invitation
but it's an invitation that comes with a
cost for the plant
some of those exudates are nutrients the
plant themselves
could use so why spend them on an
invitation
what can the microbes bring in exchange
well for one microbes help plants access
nutrients they might have trouble
getting on their own
above ground plants can access carbon
dioxide
water oxygen and light and below ground
they get structure and many of the
additional mineral elements they need to
survive
but some elements like nitrogen are
pretty difficult for plants to get
nitrogen is essential for life
and it is also plentiful but it is so
difficult to convert nitrogen into the
forms
life needs and plants aren't
able to do that instead they rely
on the bacteria of the rhizosphere
to take nitrogen and convert it into
ammonia and other compounds that they
can actually use
some plants like legumes even form
nodules on their roots to house those
bacteria
creating an even tighter symbiotic
relationship
now whenever you invite someone over
there's a little bit of a risk to that
especially when
you know sometimes people misunderstand
the nature of the invitation
releasing compounds that attract
bacteria is all well and good
until the pathogens also catch wind of
what's going on
sometimes these pathogens make it to the
plant and are able
to infect it but then other times the
non-pathogenic bacteria
can shield the plant creating protective
biofilms or releasing toxic compounds
that target the pathogens
like your good friends that help you
kick that guy out who
i don't think you even invited but
collecting such an active bacterial
community
is also a great way to attract predators
protozoa and nematodes alike can be
found in the rhizosphere thanks to the
buffet of bacteria
that await them and yet this is a risk
that plays
somewhat into the plants interests as
well as these predators graze on the
bacteria
they excrete nitrogenous waste that can
continue to contribute to plant growth
or in some cases the predator dies
and they become the source of nutrients
the composition of these microbial
communities is shaped by the compounds
released by the plant's roots scientists
are studying the ways these
specific molecules and the root exudate
can influence the presence of specific
bacteria and fungi
as we learn more about the rhizosphere
we may come to understand
not only how these root exudates
influence the ecology of
microbes and plants alike but how we
can better interact with it when growing
our own crops
these chemical signals and the
interactions they shape
form a dialogue between different parts
of the living world they speak a
language whose basic
vocabulary we may understand but whose
full syntax
is complex and wonderful
and mysterious
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us if our pretty
images have inspired you to create some
pretty images of your own and you'd like
some help
with that you can head on over to
skillshare where there are classes like
botanical illustration intensive
draw plants using science and style
artist and naturalist maggie harrity
will teach you to create science-based
botanical illustrations
of the plants you can find around you
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership
with meaning with so much to explore
real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
and it makes it easy with short classes
that will fit into your daily routine
a premium membership will give you
unlimited access
so you can join the classes and
communities that are just right for you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month
and if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description you can get a two-month free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
journey to the microcosmos is only
possible because of the support of our
patrons
so thank you so much to our patreon
community these people are the reason
this and all of our other episodes exist
so if you liked it say thanks to them
you can find out more about becoming a
patron at patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on instagram where he is always
posting
beautiful and fascinating things and if
you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you